hello everybody and welcome to part two
of let's play to number of the Black
Plague alright
door off clock thankfully I'm not
thankful right here anything in my
inventory so degan really
that did it oh you gotta be kidding me
that is ridiculous ridiculous that work
oh yeah oh yeah know that oh I get it I
get it would scare me
Oh lasers dead guy ah didn't you just
warn me about Carlito is waiting for you
in the mess hall with insert today's
specials here a happy worker is an
efficient worker only efficient workers
will be fed uh-huh am i in a vision
that's a guy who left me like no why did
he get killed by this laser
rashon neck our cakes and bolted the
bastards down yeah yeah get him Neal
does death did not occur gimme over this
what is going to folk know
Oh lock it all this c400 yeah got it off
so good that you're a whisper bring it
on ah get away I know that noise got a
busted got here oh yeah right here
only trust it here today's cure the
unpure out here that looks like it come
I believe that skier and not keep ah-huh
we're on chair another chair a lethal
weapon
[Music]
yeah yeah I'm a chair
Oh No I'm defenseless I'm convinced this
without my chair oh no oh yeah that's a
flare now except oh there's a cassette
player right there
Galloway chair all right my name Neal of
carpenter rank elevated to the status
code see imprisoned observing the turn
Capitol thought like if I predict that
it will be myself they visit next to my
knowledge I am the last remaining member
of the elevator aliens around Amer so it
falls upon nations to ensure that CA
protocol is not compromised for that
reason I record here in the
I have discovered bring it on
not afraid come on yeah on how much your
art that's less therefore when I come
back ah come on every door has bull crap
bull crap what do we got
Oh what's this oh you can't but I can
Oh give it a butler alcohol no shut up
John I thought you'd lose your
condescending attitude fine
oh yeah oh thank you chair huh yeah I
ripped out with my bare hands
all right this lock now come on
fine what I do I just turn the lights on
how did that help me get it open oh yeah
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah yeah where's my chair oh okay
alright you got my chair oh good make me
sure
Oh believe me everything open I wanted
to have a flashlight oh good yeah take
this oh oh so badass oh oh oh what was
it Oh
I was here
Oh what was that oh man what it's not
even fair hard to have a flashlight man
oh this kid's gonna be great
oh love it love it
come on bring it on oh it's good oh
you're right there Wow
why are you still there what am I gonna
do are you gonna go away oh I can't
bring my chair with me
hey if not going crouched oh all he's
much more persistent than the amnesia
monsters I just got a run past it where
- I don't know where go I got a syringe
[Music]
okay all right that's that's something I
guess oh I filled with air and I jab it
in the monsters neck that's so
yeah oh yeah I can't inject a door
stupid that wasn't my idea I don't know
I don't know I don't know but
all right let's try this bring it that's
what I thought yeah yeah oh I'm not in
there you're so stupid
oh don't even think about coming down
here don't I got a chair again bring it
on
I'm not I'm not pure way oh you like
that oh oh oh ah are you naked why are
you naked eyes everything naked Oh what
is it with frictional games and things
being naked how do I get past that thing
what do i do what do i do oh oh I gotta
get past it cuz it opened the door okay
all right Oh
bring it on are you jump oh [ __ ] oh yeah
oh so great Oh phenomenal oh look at
this
get away get away huh alright I gotta
wait for him cuz that middle room I
gotta go to the middle room I don't know
why suddenly they become unlocked just
the power going out but I gotta go in
the middle room I'm gonna wait three
potatoes until he gets to
potato potato let's go
all right let's make a snake oh now
you're in the middle room you Becca you
[ __ ] off of you you I'm going in
anyway oh oh oh oh yeah oh oh what now
get away oh yeah oh yeah you ain't got
nothing nothing ain't got nothing
nothing at all can you follow me
arrows thank you I know where to go all
right that was fun
that really was I like that I gotta cut
it here thank you so much for watching I
will see you in part 3 of let's play
penumbra the Black Plague bye bye